[Musique]
je peux pas prendre mon bon c'est fait
monsieur buisson il va pas être contente
alors sache contact est toute simple un
bien est ce que tu crois que l'image
qu'on aide toi lac est très gentille
petite robe blanche des grands cheveux
correspond à ce que tu es étranger
kahlaoui pas forcément puisque je suis
en robe blanche avec de longs cheveux
d'accord on forcément quelque chose ça
me paraît évident tu veux dire est ce
que je dévoile un aspect caché et
profond de moi même j'en sais rien c'est
à vous de me le dire moi je sais pas ce
que je suis je me demande pourquoi c'est
toujours des filles à qui on demande de
jouer à ce petit jeu comme ça je dévoile
mon moi intérieur avec tact et
intelligence sera beaucoup plus drôle si
vous faisiez avec des garçons
non c'est à quelques fois quand sec
devrait mettre un garçon en oui très
fort de la puberté jusqu'à il ya
quelques années oui très très fort très
violemment puis maintenant ça c'est
complètement calmés cela dit je trouve
quand même con qu'on traverse une
période très très très pénibles parce
que c'est c'est devenu courant de dire
qu'il ya plus de ya plus de misogynie au
même titre d'ailleurs qu'il ya plus de
racisme et moi je trouve que c'est tout
à fait le contraire parce que avant au
moins la misogynie elle seule elle se
cachait un petit peu derrière des lois
qui était vraiment foncièrement qui est
égalitaire entre les hommes et les
femmes est maintenant bien qu'il n'ya
plus il n'y a plus une aussi grande
distance entre entre les la façon de
traiter l'homme et la femme la société
encore qu'il ya des injustices
absolument invraisemblable enfin disons
qu'il ya un progrès en ce sens la
misogynie elle prend une allure tout à
fait autre elle et elle est très très
inquiétante est à mon avis très très
dangereuse parce que la plupart du temps
c'est elle prend le visage du
paternalisme car ces grains plus belle
la plus sensationnelle la place à celle
là est la plus l'appeler et tout ça j'ai
pratique 30 ans
mais t'es con la rencontre on se déroule
à la poule à la lie à la voilà
[Musique]